other candidates hi candidates on the
platform
recordings we're gonna have your
attention please I three mcmillan
returning officer for the Eastern Shore
constituency to clear that the total
number of votes given to each candidate
or disposed green stratton cutting
Scottish Liberal Democrats 1069
robert e lee UK Independence Party 888
deal it under Montgomery Scottish
conservative and unionist 1400s
do you smoke be your this to Murphy
Scottish Liberal Party 19,200
Kirsten Frances Oswald scottish national
party 22
notice the Kirsten plans audible is duly
elected as a member of parliament for
the Eastern Shore constituency
the total number of votes cast across
israel show at the UK parliamentary
election or seven with me was fifty 6825
level total number above he was rejected
while identify the resume our pinterest
were rejected because they did not give
the official mark 50l he was rejected
because i was forgiven for more than one
candidate 0 pallet people's be rejected
because there was something written were
marked on the paper of which torch was
identified and 18 ballot papers were
rejected it was remarked or more
aggressive today can I thank you for
scalp of alternative country no it's um
thank you for the accuracy and achieves
Mukunda there will be a number of
speeches if at first we can ask kristine
francis oscar to control
I look like to thank the police the
return of serve had told her style or
they're fantastic we're entering the day
and today I'd also like you'd like to
hang over my opponents and what's been a
very energetically for campaign here I
had an exceptional team working
incredibly hard for my campaign no one
could have done more than they did and
their support has been amazed thank you
also to my family for their endless
patience as or to the last few months
above all I would like to thank the
people initiative to share placing their
faith in me geography than the ASAP I'm
absolutely honored to be elected as they
compete for each train for sure I will
work tirelessly every single V for the
people that were than ever local
communities here I'm weathering for
today say P in the selection or notes
and where were your reviews on
Scotland's future I will seek to
represent every single one of the people
in this area to the very least of my
ability
and this election is about making our
beliefs carrots are voiceless trade for
Sharon our voice of course opens would
effectively in ways then stir than ever
before and I'll do everything I can to
build unity as I go read this and
working task that people entrusted women
and I'll use that for it's not just to
improve Scotland's but also to pursue
tree racing policies which will be in
flippity eliminated Kingdom and it has
looks like cleaner in elected alongside
a strawberry who base ap mps then we
will work together to into a names of
steady tea cups which are hurting people
and communities north and south of the
border and we will call for the parish
tourists and spoken to the referendum
starting with the parents that make the
biggest impact on getting more people
into work and making work poppy and as
part of a group restore guess nvm PS i
will always vote against wasting 100
million persons or a new generation of
we've increased and waste and things
that really matter to the people in
Scotland things like the any chase the
people of you strangers around the
people in Scotland are speaking and we
needs to listen to them it's tape for
every story here from Westminster thank
you
I'd like to start by thanking of least
not just for the what they've done today
and securing the election but for the
work of the do every day and securing
our communities I'd like to thank you
for funding also than all of us stuff
for professional wave which the kind is
conducted I'm until the thanks to my
agent Paula cake and my brilliant
campaign team for what so hard all sorts
of Evers over the past few weeks real
tribute to the little party never been
to the thousand virtue and to the
campaign I'd also like to congratulate
custom for her victory and David Robert
and blame to the spirit in which the
local campaign has been fallible as we
all know each day of the trial is unique
in Scotland and its diversity with a
large Jewish community and a growing
miss what romantic with notion schemes
and some of the richest parts of
Scotland within each man for sure it has
been a real pleasure to represent
earlier and Parliament for the past 18
years Justin I know what it's like to
come from behind and an election and
this is citizen and I thought of you
will cherish the opportunity to move
Bishop has provided you with i whole
heartily congratulate you and wish you
every success and your parliamentary
career and standing up to the people of
your generation as well as having had
the honor of representing New Hampshire
on Parliament I've also had a chance to
serve government's Labor Government's
under the cabinet
and brought employed and I'm fo verse 13
years and we changed our country for the
better and an irreversible win this is
of course an anonymous moment for the XM
here no one can deny dark and I
congratulate them more widely on their
success this evening with a victory on
this skill but also comes a
responsibility no one of course should
ever confuse his nationalism with our
nation no one should ever mistake their
party for our country because our
history our streets of flag have never I
will never belong to one political party
or one political comments and finally
his proven house sits on ruined years of
difficulty the Scottish Labour Party in
just five short months tonight Scotland
has lost so many great members of
parliament from all across the country
and a late to pay tribute to each every
one of them they were going to see ever
this and what it means for Scotland in
the days to come but for me personally
and for the Scottish Labour Party the
find is on and of course continuous I
and hundreds of thousands of Scots the
length and breadth of our great country
still believe in the progressive
policies for the Labour Party status 1
and I will continue to lead scottish
labour as we fight for them the path to
that has traditionally been detained as
champion of the underdog now finds
itself with a position of being the
other development but the Scottish
Labour Party has been around for more
than a century and a hundred years huge
night of stale beer ever stolen needs a
short labour party and our fight aight
starts tomorrow morning
you